Speaker 1: Speaking of disoriented, I want
to play for you clips of a visibly disoriented
Sarah Palin.
Now, you might remember that Sarah Palin was
the late John McCain's vice presidential running
mate back in 2008.
Thankfully, they lost.
And she was kind of like the opening of the
door to cartoonish Trumpism, where, like,
anything goes in some way.
Palin was the predecessor to people like Trump,
Madison, Cawthorn, Marjorie Trader, GREENE,
Lauren Boebert, Herschel Walker.
As we saw the normalization of people in completely
over their heads in politics.
She recently lost her election trying to become
a congresswoman representing Alaska in the
House of Representatives of Washington, D.C.
She recently lost that, and she appeared on
the Steve Bannon Real America's Voice War
Room pandemic show, whatever that is.
And she seems to be completely disoriented.
She doesn't know what the hell is going on.
She attacks ranked choice voting.
It's completely wild.
And this was a woman who was almost a heartbeat
away from the presidency of the United States.
Think about that.
Speaker 3: Well, you call that, Steve, when
you explained what this new fangled cockamamie
system called ranked choice voting is all
about, when it doesn't matter if you perhaps
are the most popular or most qualified candidate,
I know it.
You can get a whole lot of votes, Steve, but
if you don't get enough second or third rankings
from voters who choose another candidate.
Speaker 1: Why?
Listening to Sarah Palin explain ranked choice
voting is absolutely delightful in that she
has no idea what's going on.
She doesn't even understand the system under
which she lost.
She just has no idea what it's even about.
Speaker 3: It.
You can get a whole lot of votes, Steve.
But if you don't get enough second or third
rankings from voters who choose another candidate.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: Then you're eliminated.
Or then you get second place and you don't
win in as complicated.
You explained it best.
President Trump explained it very well.
Speaker 1: And yeah, Trump really explained
this concept well.
He also explained, you know, a thermodynamics
really well, just like she would, I'm sure.
Speaker 3: Valid that he had up here warning
Alaskans that this newfangled experiment with
ranked choice voting will split votes.
It will allow liberals to skip on in, which
is exactly what's happened.
Speaker 1: Thus they can just skip on in and
vote.
By the way.
This was Trump's explanation for ranked choice
voting fraud.
Speaker 5: Fraud, fraud.
It's a.
Speaker 1: Fraud.
The idea that was his brilliant explanation.
Speaker 3: And it's a it's a very, very potentially
fraught with fraud.
Speaker 1: She has no idea to this day why
and how she lost.
She genuinely has no clue.
And then, of course, she she these people
want to use anger.
They need everybody to be angry.
That's how they operate.
And here is Sarah Palin in this same interview.
And by the way, why Sarah Palin's homes are
like the most echoey places ever.
It's like a cave I have never understood.
But here is Sarah Palin in her echoey house
saying people should be angry.
She lost at.
Speaker 3: That homes the entire nation.
So I think the entire country should be angry
at what's going on with this establishment
system.
And it was the political establishment that
created this system with the ranked choice
voting and without encouraging the other Republican
to drop out once he got thumped three times.
Others should be outraged about what's going
on here.
Right.
Our system is harming the rest of the U.S..
Speaker 1: The everything everything that
has a bad outcome to these people is fraudulent.
And it's sort of the same argument that they
would make if we figured out a way to get
rid of the Electoral College and just have
a national popular vote, which we should we
obviously should.
They would say, oh, that's harming the country.
Really?
How is it how would it harm the country that
the candidate with the most votes wins?
Well, it's not the will of the founder.
It's the exact same type of thing.
If the system leads to me losing, it's a bad
system.
And Sarah Palin, there's all there is something
comedic about the fact that she doesn't even
get how and why she lost.
And there's an amazing video from election
night a couple of weeks ago where she's like
wherever her watch party, her results party
is and the information starts coming in that
she lost and she doesn't even really get it.
And at one point, she goes over and she cuts
a cake.
And just the absurdity, the visual absurdity
of she doesn't really know what's going on,
but they do have a cake there and she's going
to move on to the cake.
It is really something to see.
They don't have any clue what's happening.
And there are a number of systems in this
country that should be reformed.
And our voting systems are some of them.
And we have to realize that even if they were
to be changed, you would then deal with years
of confused people claiming that by virtue
of the fact that they lost, it must be a bad
system.
And certainly Sarah Palin is buying into that
full speed ahead.